yeah someone asked a question about
decision making so i put up a tweet
recently that said if you can't decide
the answer is no
and uh i think that's a the reason i
have decision making heuristics that i
use uh and actually there are three
decision making heuristics that i use
and it's very hard to come up with the
decision making heuristic because
there's infinite choices we're making
all day long and
trying to figure out like some rule that
apply to all the choices is really
difficult so obviously these rules are
not going to apply to everything you
have to be intelligent about when to use
them and when not to make it when not to
use them but i'll tell you my three
decision making heuristics
first is if i'm faced with a difficult
choice such as should i marry this
person
should i take this job should i buy this
house should i move this city
should i go in business with this person
if you cannot decide
the answer is no
and the reason is because modern society
is full of options
there are tons and tons of options we
live in a planet of seven billion people
we are connected to everybody on the
internet uh there's hundreds of
thousands of careers available to you
there are so many choices
you're biologically not built to realize
how many choices there are because we
evolved in tribes of tribes of 150
people
where if you pass that one choice the
second thing never comes along
also
when you
choose something
it takes you get locked in for a long
time if you start a business that's 10
years you get into a relationship that's
five years
maybe more
you move to a city that's 10 20 years so
these are very very long-lived decisions
so it's very very important
that you only say yes when you are
pretty certain
you're never going to be absolutely
certain but you're going to be very
positive if you find yourself creating a
spreadsheet for a decision with a list
of yeses and no's and pros and cons and
checks and balances and why
you know why this is good or why that's
bad
forget it yeah you have to internalize
it in your gut and in your heart and you
have to really want something before you
go for it so my first decision making
heuristic is if you cannot decide the
answer is no
by the way i would ask everybody to hold
your questions until i'm done with the
three decision making heuristics because
i'm not reading anymore right now
the second decision-making heuristic
that i use is if you have two choices to
make
such as
you know do i tell this person a or do i
tell them b or do i
you know do i take job a or job b
or you know do i make this sacrifice now
or do i go ahead and do what i want
whatever it is if you have two choices
and they're relatively equal
choices like it looks 50 50 to you this
is key for choices where it's lopsided
you know 175 there was 25 obviously go
with a 75 but if it looks equal to you a
or b and you can't decide
take the path
that is
more difficult and more painful in the
short term
because what's actually going on is one
of these pads requires short-term pain
and the other one maybe requires pain
further out in the future
and what your brain is doing through
conflict avoidance is it's trying to
push off the short-term pain
and by definition if the two are even
and one has short-term pain that means
it has long-term gain and by the law of
compound interest the long-term gain is
where you want to go towards anyway so
your brain is over
valuing the side that has the short
short-term happiness and it's trying to
avoid the one with short-term pain so
you have to cancel that tendency out and
it's a powerful subconscious tendency by
leaning into the pain
as most of you know
most of the gains in life come from
suffering in the short term so you can
get paid in the long term working out
like for me is not fun i suffer in the
short term i feel that pain but then in
the long term i'm better off because i
have muscles or i'm healthier the same
way if i am uh reading a book and i'm
getting confused if like i can't
understand what's going on that's just
like working out and the muscle getting
sore or tired or feeling the lactic acid
but it's not just my brain is being
overwhelmed but in the long run i'm
getting smarter because i'm absorbing
new concepts sort of at the limit or
edge of my capability so
um you you generally want to lean into
things that have short-term
pain but have long-term
gain my trainer jersey gregorik
aka the creator of the happy body
he has a beautiful short saying where he
says
hard choices easy life easy choices hard
life so what he means by that is if you
make the hard choices in the short term
like oh i shouldn't eat bad carbs or
processed foods or i should go ahead and
do the workout which is difficult i
don't feel like doing it then in the
long term i'm going to have an easy life
but if i make the easy choices in the
short time it's short term like i'm
going to stay out drinking
i'm going to go party i'm not going to
do my work right now i'm not going to
meditate whatever it is then in the long
term you're going to have a very
difficult life you will not have built
up that self-discipline so that is my
second heuristic for decision making
and now i'm going to tell you the third
heuristic for decision making
the third one is a little different
the first one was focused on making the
right long-term decision the second one
was on
choosing how to split between two
otherwise even paths the third one is
about cultivating peace of mind
and peace of mind is is very important
because it is the precursor to happiness
happiness is one of those things that
cannot be chased directly if you chase
happiness directly but you're actually
chasing this pleasure and pleasure
eventually comes
uh with a uh with a withdrawal symptom
like a pleasure is a high and then you
crash down pleasure is a ferris wheel
that you get on you write it up and then
eventually you write it back down but if
you actually want to be happy if you
want to be content that comes from peace
and so the third decision-making
heuristic is if you're having
this is very helpful in times of
interpersonal conflict where you're
trying to figure out whether to say
something to somebody or not
that might make them angry or might get
something off your chest
make the choice that will leave you more
equanimous equanimous is sort of a fancy
word for internally calm and uh settled
uh make the choice that will leave you
more equanimous at the uh
in the long term uh and this one i i
can't take credit for i got it from
kapio gupta um he's on twitter as well
as kaplan gupta md
or seda performance i forget which
account he's using right now but uh
basically whichever choice will leave
you calmer in the long term is actually
the right one
if you if you walk away from making a
choice and you still have internal
turmoil uh then eventually you're gonna
want to turn around and reverse that
choice so this helps you
from having regrets
so those are kind of my three
decision-making heuristics
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you